I have lived long enough to see the same
eyes in different people I see your eyes
I know your eyes
you
hey youtubers is charlie so surprise
surprise there's new Star Wars footage
mostly focusing on race character so
let's break it down also I'm gonna go
ahead and do another giveaway for movie
tickets all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just like a gift
certificate for the value of two imax
tickets for the force awakens which i
think i think it amounts to about fifty
dollars so anyway let's get going we
start out with the Millennium Falcon
well looks like the really green planet
where this battle is taking place later
I think that's called taka Donna the
only reason we know that though is
because that name shows up as a planet
for a data entry for one of the
characters that showed up in other
promotional material here for this me8
d9 droid it refers to it as emmy you
know just like we say c-3po is Threepio
it attaches Emmy to the unlight
scoundrels of tako da da so when they're
saying an ally they're talking about not
allied with the resistance or with the
first order kind of like Cloud City
Lando Calrissian in the original trilogy
so this which actually seems like it
might be maz kanata's castle is probably
on this planet there's also rumors that
she's part of that pirate faction so
this actually might be where they find
Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber the really
important dialogue she has though is
I've lived long enough to see the same
eyes in different people I see your eyes
I know your eyes thats just a reference
to them being the children of characters
from the original trilogy I know
everyone's wondering like who is the
daughter and son of who there is a rumor
that Finn is Lando Calrissian son but
that's based on the description of this
Amazon marketing so I'm looking at that
as rather dubious I'm already totally on
board with raid being the daughter of
one of the original trilogy characters
that is not Luke and I do think that
she's related to one of the antagonists
just to be very opaque about it but I
don't know about this Finn Lando
Calrissian thing that just feels like a
version of the jokes that people used to
make about Leia like how she used to be
the only woman in the galaxy I think
there's an attempt in the new movies to
try to a more accurate portrayal of the
the citizens of the galaxy like it would
be vastly diverse vastly different
numbers of species races genders that
even be a crazy diverse population of
droids so I think it's a huge leap to
assume that just because Finn bears some
resemblance to Lando Calrissian that
he's his son automatically though there
will be children of original true
characters in this movie though but I
think this whole TV spot is more
focusing on Ray's characters so I think
that line refers mostly to Ray here we
see han solo on the ice planet which is
not hot but definitely invoking a lot of
empire strikes back imagery this ice
planet is where the first order base is
supposed to be and a lot of people are
wondering if the planet itself might be
hiding the Starkiller base this scene
here with finn and Poe looks like it's
at a rebel base but it also looks like
it's on the same planet as to Conda but
it makes sense that the resistance would
try to bargain with pirates to get the
supplies they needed ships weapons
anything they might want you can kind of
see how this invokes episode 4 imagery
where they're getting ready to go on the
final assault on the first Death Star
only don't see Han Solo taking his money
and running this is just Imperial
transports flying overhead here's ray
getting ready to get into a fight with
her staff on jakku can't can't wait to
see her fight with the staff I know a
lot of people want this to be like a for
spike or something I don't think that
she's going to have a lightsaber right
away if she's going to be for sensitive
I think she's only going to figure it
out later in the movie that's what I
think a lot of that Matt's cannot a
dialogue from the previous trailers
about the forces comic to you let it in
I think she's talking to both Finn and
Ray this huge structure here looks like
the Starkiller base just just invoking a
lot of Death Star imagery kylo Ren
defecting blaster fire Darth Vader Cloud
City style then ray gets a punch it
chewie moment as she flies what looks
like through this forest here so like I
said the TV spot in general just
focusing on ray badassery although we do
see a couple of the other planets the
interesting thing about the movie is is
that a lot of the locations a lot of the
costumes will invoke imagery from the
original trilogy but they'll be new
planets Dooku looks like Tatooine taco
Donna looks like indoor you get the idea
so everybody get hype and let me know
like who do you think that Ray's parents
are regardless of who the other
characters might be related to I feel
like there's a pretty obvious choice
based on the marketing of the film but
what I'm going to do for the giveaway is
it'll just stay open till I post my next
star wars video and there is a warcraft
giveaway that's going on right now i'm
giving away an epic warcraft mount from
the the trailer that i posted the other
day so that's going to go down to the
next Warcraft video that I post will
should be sometime later this week so a
couple cool giveaways happening in if
you guys are confused about like when I
announced giveaway winners usually I
announce the winner in the next video
based on whatever thing the giveaway is
happening in just in case you guys
haven't
though I posted a whole bunch of Star
Wars footage you can click here to start
the loop that just like a couple
trailers a couple TV spots and some
speculation and you can click here for
the flash and Supergirl trailers from
this week four episodes that are coming
up thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight me me me me